[Music]
it's
[Music]
the talibans are i think trying to
control the economic choke points so to
pressure
the government and as well as the
population that is in the domain of the
government because with them controlling
their border crossings
um there will be difficulties in the
resupply and supply of
a lot of things to these people
if you look at the morale of the afghan
forces
obviously it is understandable that
they've been fighting for 20 years
and now they feel and see the prospects
of a civil war so morale is a law and
therefore you've seen
thousands of afghan army personnel
surrendering to the taliban without a
fight
of course there are huge implications
the taliban once they control the choke
points will actually control
the logistical lifeline into kabul
and other major cities there are frantic
efforts underway right now
and those of course include diplomatic
efforts
[Music]
there's also a high level afghan
delegation heading to doha for talks
with the taliban those talks of course
are going to be crucial what pakistan
wants
is a political settlement it wants to
avoid the scenario of a civil war in
afghanistan
it wants the regional states to play a
more proactive role
in trying to convince both parties that
is the afghan government
as well as the taliban that they must
come to a negotiated settlement
rather than risk plunging afghanistan
into another cycle
of violence
you